fifty years ago this week the despair of
a city led to devastation on its streets
in Newark New Jersey an unfounded rumor
that a man had died in police custody
triggered five nights of gunfire arson
and looting that left 26 people dead and
neighborhoods in ruins a half-century
later what's the legacy of the Newark
riots Michelle Miller is here with more
Michelle good morning good morning the
uprising that happened in New Jersey's
largest city in 1967 quickly spread and
soon reached cities like Detroit it was
a long hot summer for law enforcement
who were blamed by residents for Fanning
the flames of intolerance in these
communities that they served those who
remember 1967 as the Summer of Love may
have forgotten what happened that year
in cities like Newark New Jersey we will
not tolerate violence we're going to
crush violence in this city for nearly a
week
residents clashed with police after a
cab driver named John Smith was beaten
by officers of the fourth Precinct it's
not dragging me through the streets in
this evident land since the people of
the community and that precinct had a
notorious reputation people thought
Smith had been killed Lawrence ham who
leads the peoples organization for
progress was 12 years old in his city
caught fire
[Music]
this was an explosive period when they
think of riots they think of Newark
Detroit happened two weeks after this
was happening all over the country
you had these majority black cities or
majority black communities and they were
patrolled by nearly all white police
forces and abusing people violating
people's constitutional rights we
citizens have the right to repeal the
most famous writer from Newark amiri
baraka he was nearly beaten to death by
the police what is responsible for this
violence for this rebellion is the
inability of the city government to feel
as human beings the plights of the
majority of the people in this city and
that is the cause of this violence
Newark native America was a poet
playwright and political activist his
consciousness his personal ideas the
things that he would doing them in a
community was changing and in fact was
becoming more escalated his son rass
Baraka is now New York's mayor here you
are 50 years later running that very
city in that very Police Department God
has a sense of humor you think so how
has life for the citizens of Newark
changed since 1967 Newark is a world
away from 1967 in some places and in
some instances we still there
emotionally I think a lot of folks still
in 1967 because we have not really
grappled with that we have not dealt
with it there have been efforts over the
decades to distance this city from its
past
most of Newark's high-rise housing
projects have come down and blocks that
were burned half a century ago have been
redeveloped and while many display small
businesses left town after the summer of
67 fit right fashions moved just a few
blocks away I moved on or all these
customers they had no way to me
in 1926 Monroe biermann's father opened
this neighborhood dress shop which now
ships worldwide a lot of people updated
even today then you mentioned or not you
used to the good news is is that Noir
recovered it took a long time and it
took a long time for Newark to turn the
corner but there hasn't been a decade in
the United States of America since then
when there hasn't been an uprising in
some city what we talk about Rodney King
we talk about Ferguson we talk about
Baltimore it'll continue to happen
because the conditions that caused the
rebellions in the 60s are still present
in places in America today this
relationship between community and
police it's not just a Newark problem
this is a problem nationwide so how do
you prevent another long hot summer what
is this a few differences right so now
you have people of color or the majority
population here in in authority and
power right so you haven't been a police
department you have missed city
government in 1967 that was non-existent
you put your police force in places
where people can see them other than the
relationship that they have of cop and
criminal the police showing up with
somebody do something bad you have the
police present when things are okay
though
long cited among America's more
dangerous cities last year newer claimed
its lowest crime rate in 50 years and
the city's population is on the rise
what's on the horizon here what do you
see from Newark in the next 5 10 15
years no ik is like it's changing very
very fast as the economic boom here we
have billions of dollars worth of
development happening in his downtown
area and it's spreading out into the
neighborhoods very very quickly Newark
has an opportunity to be a model for
many many cities around the country
Mayor Baraka also says we often miss
characterize what happened in his city
as a riot a riot he says is what rowdy
sports fans do after a victory what
happened in Newark was not as
spontaneous tensions had been simmering
there for a very long time like his
father who didn't live to see him become
mayor Muraki considers what happened 50
years ago an uprising he's not alone
I've talked to people in Detroit in LA
rebellion uprising and a lot of folks
say it was both a riot and uprising a
rebellion great distinction between
those and the idea also that it's the
issues not that response but the issues
that if you don't solve those you go
back to the same thing they could where
we are with community policing look
where we are with police brutality look
where we are today in terms of people
being held accountable on both sides no
it's a long ago but not so long ago it's
very interesting Michelle Miller thank
you thank you thanks for having me
appreciate it